hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason I o
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied in taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to YouTube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well chapters 20
through 23 of the Mona loggia contain a
line of argumentation that handsome is
engaging in about God or the divine
substance and space he's also touching
out of time as we've talked about in
another core concept video and he's
doing so in a parallel way because the
way use in which God is related with
time are parallel to those in which God
is related space and they can really be
understood as connected with each other
although the lines of argumentation is
ansel will say do diverge from each
other now the discussion of space is a
little bit more contained it's not
spread out through point so many
chapters just chapter 20 through 23 and
I think it's a little bit easier to wrap
your head around them the discussion of
time in perfect spaces easy for us to
visualize and time requires a bit more
in a work of the intellect or the
imagination on our part so the question
that Anselm is concerned with is the
following what is the nature of God in
relation to space inserts up my
asking in chapter 20 does God exist
everywhere is actually everywhere and
always somewhere and sometimes or
nowhere and at no time and he wants to
eliminate the nowhere yeah somewhere and
he does so it in chapter 20 by pointing
out that if God exists nowhere then
we've got a problem because things are
on to logically dependent on God for
their very being as you know you can
check out the video in particular about
participation this is something that an
some does think that if God isn't
somewhere then how can anything
literally be there and it's not going to
work to say that God it is just
somewhere and not somewhere else because
if that's the case then God is you might
say leaving that place in the lurch as
well so he says you know since no good
thing exists without him if he exists
nowhere every good thing exists nowhere
if he exists determinately somewhere and
sometimes in some place it's only in
that place where and when also that he
exists that anything Kansas so if we
want to say good luck we we know the
things exist that's experientially a
starting point for us and we did you
know move from space to space space God
as this you know fundamental you might
say undergirding principle of being has
to also be there so the questions that
then arise are concerned with thinking
this out further we know that space is
on the one hand continuous but it's also
divisible and discreet so that here is
not the same thing as this here it's the
same thing even with virtual space all
right you saw me move from one spot to
the next and you you know it's the same
it's a different spot on your screen or
watching this app or imagining in your
in your head but you know even with
virtual space you can't have two things
generally occupying the same spot at the
same time or can you well that's that's
something we're gonna have to think of
them so he goes on he says you know God
is not a competent right why did he
bring this up he says does he exist as a
whole everywhere this could be
understood in two ways either he exists
as a whole all at once in all places and
by parts in individual places or exists
as a whole even at each individual place
so would it make sense to say that a bit
of God exists over here and say causes
the being of that over here and then
another bit of God is over here and
another bid is over by you and so on
insulin says no because we've already
seen that God is perfectly simple and
actually to be a composite being is in a
way not as good as being a simple being
so that's not going to be of the nature
of God either now that then seems to
raise another problem doesn't it because
okay so God is not a competent he has to
exist as a whole everywhere that means
that gown is this is a hole here and God
exists as a whole year and here now that
seems to raise some problems as well
doesn't it you notice that with each of
these the solution leads to yet another
problem does that mean that God that
exists as an individual hole at every
sort of individual place an Ansel is
going to explore this in considerable
detail with the hampshire's know but
let's take a look at that that argument
he says if he exists as a whole in
individual places individual holes exist
in individual places just as one place
is distinct from another place in such a
way that they are individual places what
exists as a hole in one place is dis
from what at the same time exists as a
whole in another place how can we model
this pieces of chalk whole piece of
chalk is credit here right well at least
the piece of track that's left smaller
piece of track this whole piece of track
over here we want to sort these are the
same thing and you can see right now
they're not the same thing right and you
can see that they're not the same thing
not just because they're different
lengths or something like that let's
actually pick one that's a little bit
closer that would be a little bit more
plausible they're not the same thing is
this one's here this one's here right
that's the logic of spatial reality as
we experience it this hand is not the
same thing as this hand even if I put
them together tres Monsieur men they're
not occupying the same space they're
distinct individual things does this
mean that the God who is over here as a
whole is distinct from the guy who is
over here as a whole it might seem to
imply that and that would lead us to not
just you know say four or five guides it
would lead us to having the entire
universe being for vain good at every
single point by a God of that place and
space right and Ansel wants to avoid
such a conclusion because you know if
you think of the absurdities involved so
he says here we go if something exists
as a whole in a given place there's
nothing of that thing that does not
exist in that likes this is why when
we're thinking about creative things we
assume that they have to be different
from each other if they're in different
places he says if there's there's
something that's hear everything that's
there has to be there and not over here
so he says therefore if something exists
as a whole in a given place there's
nothing of it that exists at the same
time in some other place so something
that exists at the same time so
something exists as a whole when I get
in place how can that whole exists at
the same time in some other place
if nothing of it can exist in any other
place this is a problem so he goes and
says since one hole cannot exist as a
whole all at once at individual places
it follows that if anything exists as a
whole all at once in individual places
it exists as individual holes in
individual places so this would mean
that the supreme nature would be in
effect split up there would be as many
says individual supreme nature's is
there could be individual places and
that doesn't make any sense so what's
the conclusion of this God doesn't exist
in every single place as a matter of
fact you could apply the same logic to
every single place and so you can
actually say that God exists nowhere but
wait a second isn't that a problem since
we have just been asserting that God
exists everywhere how can God exists
everywhere and exists nowhere at the
same time well this is where we get to
chapter 22 and in it the insulin is
going to hear ya a move that he does or
and over again through his works very
important distinction making where
you'll say we make an assumption we're
not really entitled to make and then
extrapolated that into something else so
when we think about a created beings the
beings that we experiential they
encounter do most of our reasoning about
are talking about the logic that he's
elaborated here doesn't need whole hold
on but it doesn't for the divine and he
even it implies that it might not apply
to some other things as well what is the
issue here he says perhaps the supreme
nature exists in place in a way that
does not prevent him from existing as a
whole all at once of individual places
but now so there are several holes but
only wonderful why this law of place and
time seems to constrain only those
things that exist
in place your time in such a way that
they do not transcend the expanse of
space or the duration of time we're
interested in the expanse of space so he
goes on and he explains this in terms of
space and he says it seems correct to
say that the thing has a place only if
its quantity is circumscribed by a place
that contains it right my hand has a
space it's here because there actually
is a place that contains now it's over
here different place similarly
containing it so he says a thing that
you know has time in the same way if
something is such that its size or
duration is not set against any boundary
whether it my place your time no no time
or place properly applies to it since no
place does to it what place does we may
reasonably say that no place is its
place so this is what allows us to say
that literally speaking according to one
way of thinking about it God isn't in
any individual place and yet God is also
in every single individual place
everywhere he says no law of place
anyway it constrains the nature that has
that no place and closes it any
confinement so what does this mean what
is the upshot of this for the Supreme
Being he says if that supreme essence is
set to exist in a place even though that
very same expression is used both of him
and localized or temporal nature's
because of our customary way of speaking
there is a different meaning because of
the dissimilarity of the things
themselves when it comes to here's an
important distinction he's making when
it comes to localized or temporal
natures they are presence at the times
and places in which they're said to
exist and they are contained by those
times placed
we associate those two together being
present and being contained in some is
saying that yes for all those things
that actually does apply that
identification is legitimate however in
the case of God were presumably anything
else that would be so you know a lot of
those lines while he is present at every
space he is not contained within that
space why because God actually
encompasses every space is entirely
present at every space and you might say
as Ansel does / there my pervades every
space or you could say interpenetrate
every space so it goes on in chapter 23
and he says it's better to understand
God as existing everywhere rather than
as existing in every place what does
that mean he says the supreme nature
does not exist in all places any more
than in all existing things not as if he
were contained by them but because he
contains all of them by pervading them
why should we not say it to exist
everywhere in the sense that he has
understood as existing in all existing
things rather than merely as existing in
all places and ansel so this is really
the right way to think about it answer
to a coma and he says we often quite
properly use place words for things that
are not places and are not confined with
any boundaries of place so he uses for
an example of this saying that
understanding is there again the solar
rationality is is the sole location of
spatial location no but we use this
spatial language this metaphorical
language in order to make sense of that
so he says they are and where our place
words yet the soul does not confine
anything and understanding and
rationality are not confined with any
boundaries of plates so even more so for
the supreme nature he says the truth of
the matter is the supreme nature would
be more rightly said to exist
so that is understood as existing in all
existing things rather than as merely as
existing in all places so it's a very
important distinction that handsome is
making he's not saying that logic
doesn't apply to the divine nature or
the divine substance didn't say know
that the logic that we apply to creative
things by which we identify or conflates
containing and presence doesn't actually
apply it to the divine and leads us
astray so if we can get rid of that
mistaken way of seeing it we can wrap
our heads around what it would mean to
see that God exists everywhere and also
at the same time in a certain way
nowhere